شكرا انك استقبلنا اليوم للحديث معك
الان نحن في معسكر لكم كم عدد العناصر
الموجوده في هذا المعسكر
شكرا لكم ايضا ومرحبا بكم
للاجابه على سؤالك لا يمكنني اعطائك الرقم
الدقيق هناك مئات من قوات البشمركه في
الجبال ليس هنا فقط لدينا قوات بشمرقه
متمركزه في مواقع اخرى ايضا كم عدد عناصر
البيشماجا التابعين لحزب كاملا في كل
كردستان العراق وليس في هذا المعسكر فقط
هل رمى لا يمكنني مشاركه هذه المعلومات
لديها عدو وحشي مثل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
نحن باستمرار تحت المراقبه والتهديد من
قبل قوات الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ينفق النظام
مبالغ كبيره لجمع معلومات استخباراتي عن
قواتنا ولمهاجمتنا لذا انا اسف لانني لا
استطيع الاجابه على هذا السؤال
او اماره
هذا يدفعني يسوع الاخر
ما هي الاجراءات او الشروط التي تضعونها
للعناصر الجديده التي عليها او ترغب في
الانضمام لكم مثل ما ذكرت بان كما رقابه
تم عمليه تجسس عليكم ما الذي يضمن بين هذه
العناصر الجديده لا تنتمي للاستخبارات
الايرانيه
الاعضاء والجدد الذين ينضمون الى حزبكم لا
يخضعون لعدد من عمليات التحقق اولا لقد
اخذنا جذورا من المجتمع الكردي وبالتالي
لدينا قاعده دعم كبيره في المجتمع لذلك
نحن قادرون على اجراء فحوصات خلفيه لاولئك
الذين ينضمون الينا يساعدنا هذا في تحديد
الاعضاء الجدد ومن اين اتوا ومن اي عائله
بعد تلك الخطوه الاولى لدينا مؤسستنا
الخاصه لمكافحه الارهاب والتي تحبط خطط
استخبارات النظام الايراني يقوم كادر
مكافحه الارهاب التابع بمقابله الاعضاء
الجدد ولدينا خبره في تلك الوحده هذا لان
لدينا 40 عاما من الخبره في النضال ضد
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
يمكننا تحديد العوامل المحتمله التي قد
يرسلها النظام هل لديكم عناصر
او خلايا في داخل الايراني
لكردسان ايران نحن حزب تاسس في كردستان
الايرانيه ونحن ننتمي الى هناك قوات
البشمركه التي تنضم الينا هنا هي التي
تعرضت للاضطهاد من قبل الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه وتقيم قيادتنا هنا والا فان
قاعدتنا الاساسيه هي داخل كردستان
الايرانيه انشطتنا التنظيميه تجري داخل
كردستان الايرانيه القوه التي لدينا هنا
ليست سوى جزءا من القوه الكليه التي لدينا
يضم حزب كوملى عددا اكبر من اعضاء الحزب
وقاعده دعم اكثر من تلك الموجوده في
كردستان العراق والجبال نعم يوجد مقرنا
هنا في كردستان الايرانيه هل كان لديكم اي
دور في المظاهرات الايرانيه الاخيره نظام
الايراني يقول انكم من تسببتم في هذه
المظاهرات او قطم المظاهرات دعوتم اليها
وسلحتم
بعض المتظاهرين
انها دعايه من قبل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه لم
ننقل اي اسلحه للمتظاهرين داخل ايران لا
يحتاج الناس لان يكونوا مسلحين طالما
لديهم قوه جماعيه موحده قد يكون لدى بعض
الاشخاص اسلحتهم ولكن هذه هي ما يمتلكونه
دائما منذ سنوات عديده كانوا قادرين على
اخذ تلك الاسلحه من المؤسسات القمعيه
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه
اخذوا تلك الاسلحه من نفس القوات التي
جاءت بنيه القتل كان لنا تاثير على
الاحتجاجات في ايران شرطه الاخلاق في
طهران نفس شرطه الاخلاق البعيده عن
الاخلاق قتلوا تلك المراه الكرديه ومن
الواضح اننا لن نسكت عن مثل هذه الجريمه
دعونا شعبنا في كردستان الايرانيه
للاحتجاج على القتل الحكومي لجينا اميني
حتى يتمكن الناس من رفع مطالبهم والمطالبه
بمحاكمه المسؤولين عن القتل نعم لقد
شاركنا في الاحتجاجات ونتواصل بشكل مستمر
مع شعبنا داخل كردستان الايرانيه لماذا
لديكم معسكرات في كردستان العراق اما هو
وايران رجيمك ديموقراطينيه ايران ليس
لديها نظام ديمقراطي بدلا من ذلك لديها
نظام قمعي هذا النظام حرم الناس من
حرياتهم ولا احد يستطيع التحدث بحريه
نحتفظ بقواعدنا في كردستان لحمايه انفسنا
وحمايه اولئك الذين تعرضوا للاضطهاد من
قبل النظام نقوم بتدريبهم ونساعدهم
ليصبحوا بشمركه لذلك اذا كنا في يوم من
الايام نحارب النظام عسكريا يمكنهم الدفاع
عن انفسهم لكن في الوقت الحالي لا نشارك
في اي نشاط عسكري ومع ذلك فاننا لا نزال
مستعدين لاي سيناريو اثناء تدريب كوادرنا
والبشمركه في اقليم كردستان علينا حمايه
انفسنا هنا ايضا
الفيسبوك تواصل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
انتهاك سياده العراق واقليم كردستان بشكل
يومي النظام ينتهك الحدود ويطلق طائرات
مسيره وينشر عملاء استخباراتيه تابعين
للحرس الثوري
نتعرض باستمرار لتهديد قوات النظام
الايراني لذلك يجب ان نكون مستعدين في
جميع الاوقات لحمايه انفسنا وشعبنا
والان هناك ثوره مستمره في ايران انتم من
المجال الاعلامي يجب ان تلاحظوا الاكراد
والشعوب الاخرين في ايران ايران مكونه من
مكونات عرقيه متعدده والاكراد هم القوه
الرئيسيه التي تقاتل النظام منذ 43 عاما
ايران يكن توني ايران
ككورد عارفه انه جنسيتك المانيه والمفروض
كنت تعيش في المانيا
ما الذي اتى بك الى هنا
من المانيا كنت في المانيا لفتره قصيره
فقط ولم اكبر هناك انا من البشمركه في
حزبكمله منذ صغر وقد شاركت في النضال
بالنسبه لي لا يمكنني ان اعيش حياه بعيده
عن شعبي خاصه الان بعد ان احتاجوا الينا
اكثر من اي وقت مضى لقد سافرت الى المانيا
فقط وكنت هناك منذ عده سنوات لكن معظم
حياتي كانت هنا
[موسيقى]